la ville est toujours sur le pied
d'alerté surveille de près le niveau de
la rivière saint françois
claudine les autorités ont fait le point
un peu plus tôt les autorités craignent
des inondations majeures chez vous
exactement que lorsqu'on parle
d'inondations majeures assure broc on
compare souvent à l'année 2010 et pour
vous montrez là quel point l'année 2010
signifie beaucoup d'eau à sherbrooke est
là qui est le pied de la fondation et
l'eau a monté en 2010 jusqu'à la limite
des briques et ça c'est justement à une
édifice municipal l'eau de la rivière
saint-françois complètement envahi ce
secteur il ya des rues aussi principal à
sherbrooke qui ont été fermées en 2010
c'est la rue king aussi une partie de la
rue king qui avait été fermé on avait
parlé de 900 évacuation pour l'instant
c'est une quinzaine de résidences qui
sont évacuées écoutons d'ailleurs le les
services coordonnateur des mesures
d'urgence à la pièce est d'atteindre
encore une fois les niveaux de 2010 sont
souvient qu'en 2010 on avait atteint 24
points 10 donc ce qui était tout près du
25 pieds au niveau des niveaux le chemin
historique à la ville de sherbrooke
c'est 20 disciplines en 1982 on espère
nos possibles pour l'instant les modèles
prévisionnels par lé 23 et 25 pieds pour
ici le centre-ville à la hauteur du pont
helmand côté des skis à d'autres
secteurs où on craint des débordements
en estrie est présentement asbestos l'on
parle d'une vingtaine de résidences qui
sont touchées par des inondations entre
autre une garderie y en aura quatre les
aussi où on se trouvait un peu plus tôt
cette semaine des commerces on a craint
aussi pour certains sites historiques
donc une grande partie de l'esprit mais
où je me trouve présentement sherbrooke
l'est et la rivière saint françois qui a
complètement sorties sont d'accord merci
beaucoup claudine